[Music]
we all know how mr. Ilan is quite the
revolutionary and he makes his own rules
and he says you know what not on my
watch I do whatever the [ __ ] I want
right you know what else he's doing
that's kind of like who you rebel yeah I
mean oh I don't yeah tell me
I do he's gonna reopen that the Tesla
factory
despite California rules of stay-at-home
ordinance isn't that gangster gangster
is he gonna do another blowtorch thing
that was super sick yeah that was being
a blowtorch imaginable
honest Tesla you could hit a button and
it [ __ ] shoots fire yesterday that's
James Bond right there that would be do
or have a tab a crossroads bond well
right now your car could dance yeah
trying fart and far as pretty dope so he
says Tesla is restarting production
today against Alameda County rules yeah
he says I will be online with on the
line with everyone else if anyone is
arrested I ask that it only be me so
more than ten thousand people work at
the factory and the company employs more
than twenty thousand people statewide so
he's like I need to get my boys into
work cuz only guys work there and um I
think it's it's awesome because we need
to get these guys paid I think so
because also the government the US
government gave permission California
gave permission and the only Alameda
came up and was like nice the County
Alameda but in every other state all of
the car manufacturers went back to work
so they're like Oh dance team yeah and
then it's also BC oil versus electric
cars I like that I know that are you
from Alameda County because I know your
account the factory is looted like
financial mouse why this is factory the
only car factory there too is that well
if he was only contractor in cuf
electric it better be damn well better
be yeah plus he like he was probably on
the first person to help out he'd
convert his factory into making
defibrillators and do all the stuff he's
like I know
and what about board what the [ __ ] are
they doing nothing
did you guys see one time he smoked weed
on Joe Rogan show really bad weed so bad
for you it could give it's a gateway
into all kinds of drugs is he on heroin
how you think hi you know I don't know
did he recently go back on Joe Rogan
yeah listen when you talked about x4 12
oh yeah I you say exactly exactly
well it's ash AES ash so it's X ash a 12
exhaustion except you're 12 it's not bad
when you say it I wish you could say it
for him everybody else who said I'm like
that's a wack name would you say that
like it's a boy name or a girl name I
don't even know if it's gender
I think it's alien Linda I think that
was his password he's like that's a dope
name try it right
so um during the whole quarantine right
I had a [ __ ] nail in my tire and I
had to go and get it fixed and all that
and I was surprised that they were open
and they're like yeah we're considered a
essential business getting your car
fixed or whatever so I'm like you bring
up a good point where is like how come
all these other factories that our
manufacturing cars can open but not
Tesla mm-hmm maybe Seagal being like we
want the oil money we want the economy
to start up again you saying that also
brings to mind I skimmed over an article
where they're Texas once Tesla to move
to Texas right yeah he says Oh
Tesla wants to move just like I'm moving
out of California is all this yeah he's
getting back slap constantly about this
it sucks man because he's the only one
doing the right [ __ ] for like the planet
yeah Colorado's inviting Tesla to come
down I recently read some [ __ ] about
that Colorado they have the space and
the people that's true well it's like
how many jobs are they losing in the Bay
Area and here's the thing with
California though as far as like big
corporations and things go most states
right
they give tack tax breaks because they
want companies to come to their state
because it creates economy and jobs and
workers and all this stuff so all the
states are back
linked each other but it's that they're
actually [ __ ] each other over cuz
it's like hey Nadine bringer Amazon over
to me let's say he's Jeff Nadine Zoe's
and then you [ __ ] come over to my
state of Delaware right and then you
bring your [ __ ] business here and
then after a while I'm like I brought
like I gotta collect some kind of tax
from you and so I started doing that and
you got Whampoa nevada then and so back
in the day california was that we had a
lot of employees we had all this stuff
and then it got to the point where we're
not collecting that much tax from all
the companies so when we start to
collect that's when they start running
away then I got [ __ ] we [ __ ] up guys
of course we were going about yeah plus
it's like their car sells obviously
because the viruses nobody's like buying
cars and doing that stuff but I don't
everyone there was like the lowest well
it's like there were one of the highest
car sales in like people are switching
over yeah so it's like damn like they
are losing shits and the money and like
especially being tough one of them like
everyone's able to start you're able to
go to a car dealership now but they
can't open up the fact that I make cars
with every single other car factory
can't do you think that they are being
selfish though bringing 10,000 people in
to like a factory to work and like
violating these orders depends on how
they do it you could argue it yeah and I
read I read this article and like yeah
and know a lot of workers in the factory
are complaining about how Elon is seeing
us just as numbers and if we get sick
he's gonna replace us all this kind of
stuff but you can argue that right very
valid especially that's why people with
pre-existing conditions should already
be very careful about all the [ __ ] right
like even they're not the ones wearing
masks at the grocery store
okay those people are already at home
hopefully isolated so but then they the
worry is that the people who do have to
go get the stuff at the grocery store or
go get food come back home and interact
with those people in some way and they
somehow get it so there is I see
concerns on both sides of it at least
with like the pre-existing conditions
and stuff like that you can still make
argument for why you can work and still
be on unemployment correct and you
should and I hope that they pay these
blows by them I hope if they pay I hope
that these [ __ ] pay these people
because I'm see I'm hearing about this
next bill they're gonna do a 64 trillion
dollar one or three 2001 and it's gonna
be another twelve hundred bucks to
people so it's like
great you got even more money this time
anything everyone else gets everyone
gets the same amount as last time like
yeah but it's like cuz with that it's
like who's actually getting the money
exactly people at the top if it's like
what that divide by how many Americans
in which bill if you if you divide that
fortunately in to all the Americans it
should be way with this hobo damn
straight why is the stock market still
running up while everyone is still
[ __ ] at home with without jobs like
the whole thing of it is the money's
going to the tippy tippy top and so the
the stock market gets to be all healthy
and run all this [ __ ]
well while people are like [ __ ] I can't
even pay rent well is it like a couple
different things with that right like
their child put out fires in different
areas I think one of the fires is
unemployment in the fact that the add-on
$600 a week on top of the regular
unemployment it's I think we're trying
to myself advised to stay unemployed
because they're making more than goal
that's on purpose it's not like it's
like oh we accidentally desensitize
people it's like hey we want people to
stay home be safe and not spread the
[ __ ] amen but but they should be they
should forgive rent too like like like
like none of this is enough for even six
I mean did you forgive mortgages I think
it's not the point where they're like
we've done all we've done and we're done
like no one's know I don't think any
problem makers are like we've we've done
it guys let's pat ourselves on the back
and stop working no I agree we're still
trying to come up with solutions I think
that's one of the problems that they've
been addressing is rent the rent issue
it's like the first fire was how do we
get people not to become homeless
through this and that's you know getting
rid of evictions it's like after that
how what do we do with back pain stuff
and I think it's like it's a lot of
problems and people are trying to find
the right answers but we're not there
yet cuz a lot of people you need a talk
it's also a lot there's still a lot of
corruption and people making millions
and billions I always try to take
advantage of the situation like for sure
well it's just the big people that the
whole reason like all these like
lobbyists and like people that are in
the gutter we're given scraps dude
that's all I'm saying
like that's what's stunning about it to
me is that I know that there are some
people in government who are trying to
do good I just don't think that many of
them are I mean I don't believe in
lobbying lobbying is like paying for
whatever you want to happen in the
government but the lobbying controls
like 90% of those market so that's why
it's all it's infiltrated by special
interest
and they're gonna get the lion's share
of the pie while the rest of us get a
very very very small fracture supposed
to be like 12,000 or 20,000 per person
what it would have been if they had just
divvied up the money right yeah and
that's for every citizen you know you
not also so with the viewpoint though do
you not believe in bailing out the
economy in any way no that I want a
bailout for the people though I also do
you how do how do you feel about you
know the stock market or even like
companies well you can't just bail out
the stock market and stuff like that
because also it that is a huge thing of
like all these people that are the
company's just giving them a [ __ ] ton of
money so they stay in business but if
you give money to the people they're
gonna have to spend it actually I'm up I
belong to the camp that believes that
maybe you should let them crash and burn
because some companies should it be
alive because they survive on just
leeching off of other people and
subsidies and things like that so for
example right like yes we have a car you
know like GM Ford and all these American
car companies that are majority actually
produced in Mexico they're not really
American anymore besides the fact that
they're incorporated here and for me I'm
like let them [ __ ] crash and burn
let's let new guys come in like Tesla
and just let the free market run itself
they say the free market but it's not no
it's an oligarchy no when they do
bailouts like this to me that's
communism that's not [ __ ] free-market
I do you feel well the let's talk about
the past then right because right now we
don't know how something's in a certain
policies is gonna affect the economy
right cuz we're not there yet how do you
feel about the recession and the
bailouts that happened then
I hated it hated it econ AG insurance
companies all those guys they got a [ __ ]
ton of money economists do look at the
bailouts that the feds did and lowering
interest rates as close to zero as
possible as saving the recession from
hitting a depression well absolutely
interest rate I would say different from
bailing out bailing out his different
part of the the the federal government
reacts stepping in and trying that's
what I mean but right but when you look
back on who've got who got foreclosed on
back then it was the people at the
bottom not the people at the top the
people that got hooked up the gut their
business is saved they didn't have to
work
about rent didn't have to worry about
mortgages people at the bottom 5.5
million people lost their homes in my
issues that after the bailout no one got
punished mmm look it up so so that's the
difference here right it's not saying
that they they do say that if they
didn't do certain steps I'm just you
know telling you guys what yeah and they
do say that if they didn't take certain
steps like with the Federal Reserve then
the the economy would have been way
worse where more people would have lost
their jobs like yeah you feel like all
of the bailouts were bad or do you feel
like everything should have just gone to
the little man
like I think that the way that they did
the bailout was was super corrupt
because because instead of I'm gonna
hand hey I know I want to paint a team's
family they're not doing well right now
I'm gonna pay any deems rich boss and
hope that they get the money to him and
his family it doesn't happen it just
doesn't happen it because like I said
five point five million people lost
their mortgage or lost their homes
during the mortgage crisis like after
the mortgage crisis when and when Obama
got elected he came to office and said I
want to I want to help these people
reconfigure their loans they didn't do
that and both parties were fine with
that
it's not a Republican or Democrat thing
it's a both yoona party [ __ ] you thing
because there's also you look at these
people that are making money is theirs
it's not that I'm in enough money it's
never that like Jeff Bezos he made
enough money that he could never lose it
right yeah but if that's not this goal
like those type of people just want more
more and more so they're gonna do
everything that I think there's a middle
ground I think that there should be a mo
ground they need to be as much help to
the little people as possible because if
a company crashes it's not that bad
because it's just mainly the the
shareholders who lose out on company
buybacks stuff like that which is the
biggest thing right company buybacks is
a big problem I think that there needs
to be steps taken if you're gonna assist
a company that has such a big part of
the economy like if you're gonna give
them money say you can't do company
buybacks and things like that so they
just did that with this last one right
yeah but they just said there's were no
stock buybacks right like rent employees
stuff like that great a step in the
right direction while still handing the
money in to Wall Street like that's what
I'm saying yeah so it's I hate to be too
cynical about it but unfortunately the
older I've gotten the
the more I realized that it's a very
simple just goes in cycles like this the
only time in history when we saw a
bailout technically happening after a
depression was I think it was a module
right the new deal with what's-his-name
Roosevelt Eisenhower and a lot of money
was that I mean that's when the damn way
Roy told about its Tony Rosa
was it Roosevelt okay and that's when
they spent you guys anything American
infrastructure like highways roads and
that's one of the arguments right is
like if we spend money creating jobs
through government funding and this is
more of the left's argument then we will
do what we did before and and spike up
the economy but economists say that
that's not necessarily what did it so
it's really difficult it's easy to go
back in retrospect and say if we didn't
do that then it would have been worse
who [ __ ] knows really I think it's
always answer who [ __ ] that's true man
but but all I know is that the way that
they've gone about this has only been
not to help the people who need help I
think and there are a lot of people
going to unemployment and that is
helping them right now I love that but
the unemployment always existed and the
ideal their funding are disagreeing
after the Great Depression that was a
biggest lesson that the matter of
government gained from the Great
Depression because and I think after
that happened they were like all right
we need to put a bill in place to give
people money yeah I'm talking about
you're in this craze like what's the
what's the point of giving the richest
people most of the money concept of
trickle-down economics have you heard of
that yeah so so basically bailout the
companies that have the most people
employed and all these things so it like
the airline industry or what have you
got to save an industry right but
there's no regulation on how they should
spend the money or let like recently
that's why last recession when they gave
AIG and all these [ __ ] insurance my
company so much money what did they do
they celebrated by spending millions on
a [ __ ] vacation and bonuses and
they're like we got this money instead
of spending and they fired a lot of
[ __ ] people instead of like you know
using it when you give a lot of money
with no oversight that's exactly what it
is so there's a balance between it and
that's exactly saying
say was unemployment has always existed
during this crisis but there are so many
people who cannot get it it's even still
even while they give you 600 bucks more
I know people who can't get unemployment
because they had a job two years ago
that paid a certain amount and they
don't qualify yeah for my argument it's
all it's like why do they get their cake
and eat it too and no punishment
especially the bankers and the mortgage
lenders and everybody who created the
recession
no one got punished for it man right
they pushed Bernanke but they didn't
really get in trouble and I think that's
the issue nobody went to jail and walk
into somebody's house who is [ __ ]
right now who doesn't have a job and
tell them that the stock market just
recovered yesterday you know there's a
there's a separation right now going on
like a class separation where people
there are people in Wall Street who it's
always gravy it's always bitching even
when things are low things are high
because they're the first to get bailed
out these we don't get bailed out and
how people are getting foreclosed in the
2008 recession is they would do this so
banks they're [ __ ] tricky right
they'll see who owes what on their
mortgage let's say you have a million
dollar home right let's say you owe only
a hundred grand on that home so you
build nine hundred thousand dollars in
equity you can't make your payment's
they're gonna come after you and say hey
you know you didn't pay your rent in the
last I mean a mortgage in the last five
tight like five months man it's i'm
repo'ing your house I'm taking it so the
bank takes it and for a very little
amount of money they just took nine
hundred grand from you and that's what
was happening to a lot of people and I
think that's the kind of predatory [ __ ]
that I don't like because these banks
get bailed out but while they're getting
bailed out they turn around and they
[ __ ] all these people so that happens a
lot and I think those are the things
that no one's really regulating or
seeing and I'm like why should they get
built bailed out and instead of going
hey we got bailed out so I know you guys
can't make the mortgage payment it's
cool it should chicle down that way but
they get bailed out and then they [ __ ]
other people who aren't paying them back
and it's a nightmare to them that the
money could go to the people who would
be buying the mortgage yeah because they
entire our entire banking system is
based on people getting into debt so
that they have to constantly overpay for
what they're bought what they bought and
that's a fair trade right that's what we
all agree to but that this protects that
system and doesn't let the people at the
bottom buy their own homes like instead
the banks get to buy cheaper cheaper
mortgages and then they get say spared
when they're one they run out of money
[Music]